- [Interviewer] All right Jolie.
Jolie where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Jolie] I grew up in
Winnebago, Nebraska.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- [Jolie] I didn't have a father.
I grew up not having a father
but my mother was always present.
My family was present
through most of my childhood.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- Well, I was raised
in the system partial,
partial adolescent years.
All the way till I graduated. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. And what kind of kid
were you in high school?
- I was different.
I was very different.
I was one of the few and
Boys Town on Nebraska
that was allowed to keep my
hair because of my culture,
and I had long hair down to my back and-
- [Interviewer] So they
would have the girls
cut their hair short?
- No, but I guess growing
up, in the system like I had
they had strict, strict policy
for like males and stuff,
but not that I'm really male, but-
- [Interviewer] So are you transgender?
- Yeah, no I'm intersex.
- [Interviewer] So you're oh intersex,
oh it's like they used
to call it hermaphrodite?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I see interesting.
So during the high school years,
you looked more like a boy?
- No, I've always looked really
feminine most of my life.
- [Interviewer] And so you
trade yourself as a female
back then?
- Yes. That's why-
- [Interviewer] You always did have?
- Yeah, that's why I
ended up leaving Boys Town
I actually went and I graduated
at Remsen Union High School.
- [Interviewer] Oh so you
were going to a boys school?
- No I was going to a boarding school.
It was like a private
school until I was 18
and then I graduated in Remsen, Iowa.
- [Interviewer] And-
- 'cause I ended up leaving
to pursue my transition
and stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] So when you say transition
what kind of transitions?
- Well I didn't find out till
later on that I was intersex
but till just recently
like within the last years
or something.
I didn't find out that I
had a reproductive organ
and stuff until I got-
- [Interviewer] Oh you have a vagina?
- No, I have well, I have male parts.
- [Interviewer] You have a penis?
- Yes but I have ovaries and stuff.
I didn't find out until
I got pregnant this year.
- [Interviewer] Oh so you're pregnant?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] How'd you get pregnant?
- I just got pregnant-
- [Interviewer] But do you have a vagina?
- No I don't.
- [Interviewer] How would the sperm-
- I don't know it's just science I guess,
I'm not sure it just happened.
- [Interviewer] Do you
know who the father is?
- No, actually I have an idea
but I'm not really quite for certain.
- [Interviewer] But
(interviewer laughs)help me.
(Jolie laughs)
- I know right?
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry if
I'm nosy but at some point
whoever the father was, can
do inseminate you somehow.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And what's
your wildest guess as to where
that might've-
- Occurred of well-
- [Interviewer] What part of your body?
- I don't even know I couldn't say.
I just know that I became pregnant.
- [Interviewer] How many months are you?
- Like four weeks probably, four weeks-
- [Interviewer] You're
four weeks pregnant.
And you don't who the
father is for certain?
- No, I do have an idea
but I don't want to say-
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- who it is.
(Jolie laughs)
- [Interviewer] All right
it's getting sticky.
So you're living down here on Skid Row?
How long you been down here?
- I've been down here like a year while
I've been down here quite some time.
I've been on and off since like 2016.
- [Interviewer] So you left Nebraska?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
- I left at like 19, 20.
I ran not too long after
I graduated high school.
- [Interviewer] And came down here?
- Yeah, no actually I went
to Orlando, Florida first
and then I went back home
and then I came out here.
- [Interviewer] Well that's
okay. And have you worked?
- No, I actually it did
have a job, like a job.
- [Interviewer] Job.
- Yes I had a job doing
street maintenance,
temporary street maintenance.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And today you are living where?
You're in a tab?
- I'm leaving downtown in my apartment.
- [Interviewer] You have an apartment?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Okay. And are
you using some of the drugs
that are down here?
- No.
- [Interviewer] You're not?
- I used to but I quit doing that stuff.
- [Interviewer] How do
you support yourself?
- Financially?
- [Interviewer] You date people?
- No I don't. I don't date.
- [Interviewer] You don't do that okay.
- No, I just have my, you know,
I just have my government
funds and stuff like that.
- [Interviewer] And do
some of your nail admirers
take care of you?
- Yeah.
Just my government benefits.
- [Interviewer] But did you
say your male friends take care
of you sometimes?
- Yeah. Yeah kinda sorta, but
mostly I'm just independent.
- [Interviewer] Yeah okay.
And I wa-
(interviewer laughs)
(Jolie laughs)
I'm gonna get nosy.
I'm gonna get punched in the nose.
So where do you think if a guy wanted
to get at your ovaries?
How he could do that?
(Jolie laughs)
- I don't know. I have no idea.
It's a secret I guess.
- [Interviewer] And do you ejaculate?
- I mean, I have working
reproductive organs.
I mean, I have working
sex genitals or whatever,
yeah they work I don't know.
It's weird question.
- [Interviewer] So, so you produce sperm?
- Yeah, I have like regular-
- [Interviewer] But do
you also have ovaries?
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
Andre who lives across the
street you guys should talk.
You should get together.
- I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Compare notes.
- It's probably really different
'cause I think every
intersex case is different.
- [Interviewer] Yeah I'm sure-
- Everybody's different.
- [Interviewer] So you've
seen a doctor about this?
- [Jolie] Yes, I have. I have
a confirmal appointment coming
up in November 10th.
- [Interviewer] With the-
- [Jolie] With the OBGYN.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- [Jolie] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Well,
it'll be an interesting-
- [Jolie] Guess.
- [Interviewer] Reaction
for the better right?
- [Jolie] We'll find out.
So-
- [Interviewer] Cool. Well
I hope this all works out
beautifully for you.
- [Jolie] Yes me too I'm praying.
- [Interviewer] Are you excited?
- [Jolie] Yes I'm excited and happy.
- [Interviewer] Awesome.
- [Jolie] Very excited and
happy. Hopefully it's twins.
- [Interviewer] Really You want twins?
- [Jolie] Yeah I want twins.
(interviewer laughs)
- [Jolie] Yes
- [Interviewer] How far
did you go to school?
- [Jolie] I graduated high school.
- [Interviewer] You graduated high school
and did you have dreams
or plans with your life?
- [Jolie] I wanted to come
out here to pursue a career
in arts and entertainment but right now
I'm focusing on cosmetology
because I like to do nails
so I want to become a nail technician.
I don't have them done right now but-
- [Interviewer] And this
will be your first child
of course, right?
- [Jolie] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Did you know
you could get pregnant until-
- [Jolie] I didn't know.
- [Interviewer] And you just found out
just in the last few weeks?
- [Jolie] I think I always
knew like intuitively
like when I was younger 'cause
it's just the way that I was.
- [Interviewer] Hold on, hold on.
What about menstrual cycle?
- [Jolie] No I don't have those.
- [Interviewer] You don't have those?
I'm more confused now than I-
- Yeah I know it's kind of a study.
Well it's a complex thing so-
- [Interviewer] I'm sure it is yeah.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] So and
you have friends out here?
Do you have good friends?
- I do kind of sorta, I
had a lot of accidents
this last year, I had a lot
of cerebral damage to my head
and stuff because I was
being tossed out windows
and things like that, and
I had a lot of burglaries
and people were coming in they
were attacking me in my home
and doing stuff to my
brain and things like that.
So I have a lot of cerebral damage but-
- [Interviewer] Who's
tossing you out of windows?
- Huh?
- [Interviewer] Who's
tossing you out of windows?
- These assholes that
were like, I don't know,
they beat me up in my building and stuff
and they pushed me out a
third or second store window.
I didn't know I was blacked out.
I was completely incapacitated
when they dropped me
out the windows so that's
why I kind of have a lot
of problems with my memory and
things like that, but yeah.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
And I mean, so your family, I mean,
tell me about your experience
as a intersex person
'cause you you're attracted to men?
- Right.
- [Interviewer] And I'll bet
you some of the men down here
are very attracted to you-
- Yeah.
- For different reasons.
- And when they find out that
you have some extra stuff
they're probably even more interested-
- in the difference.
I mean, I'm sure if somebody
was in denial yeah, but-
- [Interviewer] Yeah, it'd
be a hell of a surprise
if you didn't know what was coming.
- Right well there's
all kinds of surprises.
I'm a Gemini so.
- [Interviewer] And what
are your personality traits
that you're most proud of?
How would you describe yourself?
- I like my resilience
and my sense of humor.
Yeah. I like the fact that I'm special
and I'm gifted, and I'm unique
and divine and beautiful.
Yeah creative and I'm a good artist.
- [Interviewer] What kind
of art do you create?
- I used to draw a lot in
high school but I do nails.
I like to express my artist,
my creativity through nails
and hair and stuff I
don't have like any makeup
on right now but-
- [Interviewer] But you're beautiful.
- Thanks.
- [Interviewer] And what do
you think of living Downtown
down here on Skid Row?
It's a crazy life here.
- I really don't like it that much.
I feel like repressed and
suppressed by all the, you know,
the factors in my environment
and just all around me
my foundation is not as
stable as I want it to be,
and financially I feel deprived
because I can't go back
to school like I want
and I can't get the kind
of employment that I want.
And so I'm just struggling right now.
- [Interviewer] What's the
most important lesson you feel
like you've learned?
- To never give up,
because I've been through
a lot of adversities
and a lot of challenges
as a young female, a young intersex female
and I'm still going through
these changes and yeah,
but my most important
lesson was not give up.
- [Interviewer] All right.
I wish you the best of luck
with your pregnancy-
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] And I
hope nobody throws you out
of any more windows.
- Right.
- [Interviewer] Thank
you so much for coming in
and sharing your very interesting story.
- Okay thank you.
- [Interviewer] Thank you very much.